to start off my name is olga lutena and
i work as a product analytics lead at
sumsup it's like some some substance
company that
helps you to provide kyc for different
tech companies or financial companies
another
before that i worked at vk.com one of
the largest social networks in
eastern european countries
so
one day in vk.com we made a query and
this query
had such performance
metrics
let's look at them
so click house
proceed about
2 billion rows
from the table
and elapsed this query in less than a
second so i think you already may be
impressed by that and let's then talk
about how click house may be that fast
how it can be applied in data analytics
in product analytics and
also how it is can be placed in modern
data stack
so when you have such fast database
basically you can also face with some
problems a lot of managers will have
a lot of questions for you because you
now can answer them very fast and
every question will take really quick
for you to
get some numbers and show them for
dashboards or just in one graph
yeah
so let's talk why click house is so fast
basically click house provided us with
such beautiful
gifts and you can see the the comparison
of relational database and column range
database
uh you can
just put mysql and postgre for
relational database if you worked with
them and for column oriented we will
talk only about click house today
so basically when i select some columns
for example i would like to select from
my white table
date region and a smartphone that a user
used and
when we do that in relational database
it will select these columns but
before that it will read also all the
columns that
have this
this table has
when you do this in click house it will
select only those columns that you that
you selected and will provide you data
only from
those columns
so that a
little memory will used and it will work
a lot more faster than in relational
databases
so what is click house basically
click house is a database
management system can can we call that
and it is mostly supposed to use in all
lab scenarios of work and we will also
talk about what all up is
so olap is a data discovery process
when you need a really low latency of
your data when you have a lot of queries
to your data
from analysts from product managers when
you need to
create some forecasting from the data
that you have
so it is online analytical processing
just
like that and also click house is column
oriented database as we already
mentioned and now it is used by really
giant companies like ebay uber spotify
and a lot of startups and
what is also really cool about click
house is that free and open source so
now we can
more closely look at
comparison between relational databases
and culinary entered structures
when you store your data in relational
databases uh you
just put your data in rows and
read them as rows
while in column based databases for each
column you have like a folder
in your memory and you access via select
to this particular folder
and also there are some differences in
structures of relational databases and
column oriented databases for example in
mysql you
already know that
a lot a lot of
small tables connected to each other
with primary key or
another columns that can connect these
tables
while in click house you have a really
wide one table
that connects all those tables in one
so let's talk about advantages of click
house
as i said it is applicable for all
update processing scenarios when you
have a lot of queries to do when you
have a lot of
questions to answer for analytics uh it
is free to use it is open source i know
even some startups and companies that
hire people who will full time do some
commits to open source click house
github
also click house have a vectorized
engine that makes it
even more far even faster
and besides the selecting columns from
the white table it selects only those
vectors that you need for your query
also
click house here
has a lot of custom functions and those
functions could be used for analytics it
could be used for
different ml processes and we will talk
about that also later
also click house have has a lot of
approximate calculations uh inside
like
where all the magic happens and also for
basic functions that you use on daily
basis
and we also will cover that
with the example of unique and unique
exact
functions also click house
compared with relational databases will
have multiple indexes
so it doesn't have primary key as it is
in relational databases but it has a lot
more indexes that can be used in
different ways and we also will talk
about that
uh also click how supports replication
and sharding for example if you have a
lot of machines
as we did in vk.com for example you can
replicate all your
data on those machines and save a lot of
time and data uh while processing it
um yeah
disadvantages of click house includes
also some
points and probably someone will
define others but i think that
click house can be
significantly slowed down by using joins
for example if you write
queries with a lot of joins from
different tables or even from one table
you will get a lot more
worse
performance of your query so try to
avoid using drawings try to use arrays
try to use aggregates which will
aggregate your data before
you make a select
also
data in click house couldn't be deleted
by raw in all
engines
you can do that only in collapsing
engine but most of the times you can
delete only data that is stored in one
partition and we also will cover what
partition is and how this is included in
quick house how it is used
also uh click house not fully adapted
for window functions so probably if you
already worked with
mysql you worked a lot with window
functions click house do have now
some
new window functions uh in view releases
but they're not so perfect as in
relational databases so in click house
we use mostly array functions for that
and
you do the same
algorithms that you do in sql in a
different way here
also as we know a lot of click house
tables
are white tables and they have a lot of
roles for example in vk we had like um
more than 100 rows in one table so when
you do
select all
you can just kill your cluster so
try to avoid
this
select all
opportunity
also click house is not fully suitable
for oltp as i said quick house is mostly
implemented in online analytical
processing but for online transaction
processing it is not quite well
because click house can
just
not store all the data that you need
when you
do transactions and while you're
inserting the data you can miss some uh
data while inserting so um be aware of
that and
try to use it mostly for olap
so now let's talk about engines that
click house provide
provides so
a lot of
work we do with merchandise family
engines
so basically it has
a lot of different applications of
merchandising engine from replacing
some inversion tree aggregation so all
of them have their functions and can be
applied for different
data pipelines that you have in your
company
i will talk mostly today about merch 3
because it's one of the widest
applicable engine
for a lot of
tasks that you may have
also click house have
a lot of integrational engines
you can integrate your click house with
kafka with mysql gdbc for example you
can read
from pi spark you can read click house
data via gdbc or you can just copy your
data from my scale to click house but
it's not really good because
when you copy your data from mysql you
still will do mysql queries
undercover
and for special engines uh there are a
lot of engines that could be used in
special
occasions i would say in special
tasks that you have and i will talk
mostly about materialized view because
it's something that not really every
database have
has and i will talk about dictionary and
how it also can be applied to maximize
your efficiency for your queries
so starting from merge 3 your create
table will look like that
firstly you
write all your
columns that you have for example here i
have
an example of advertisement data that i
mostly had in vk.com for example
and
you have
engine
and here we use merge 3
it's like a basic table that you will
use in analytics and then partition by
date so let's dive into partitions and
what they mean
basically partitions it's like also
folders
that stores your data
in a partition that you
provided in create table for example if
i provide it as a partition column
date
it will store my
data in some folders like that
with the number of day
which data was stored
and
also you can
get those partitions from a special
table in special scheme system in click
house so you can just look at them
understand how they are organized inside
your
table
and
now we will talk about how to
effectively use partitions in quick
house for example
you have a really large table for
example in the uk or in samsung you have
thousands of events millions of events
every day and
for such large tables with raw data it's
better to use a partition by a week or
by month
so that while
click house will merge your data while
storing it will not
spend a lot of memory for that
but when you have a smaller data you can
partition it by day as well
and you will have an opportunity to
delete by partition more precisely than
it will be with week or month
and of course you can use in
partition by key not only date time
values you can use for example
a column with
some
some categories of your
companies of your clients or something
like that if you do not have any
data columns
next one is order by keys so it's like
sorting keys in a sorting indexes as i
said in quick house we do not have
primary key as in relational databases
but basically the first one column that
you will write in order by it will be
very similar to
primary key in relational databases but
it differs from that
because
this
key can be duplicated so
it can have
more than one
presence in your data
data schema
and also
when you apply filters in where
in your rare query
the index that you
it in order by will sort all your data
before applying filtering
and that's how it looks
inside so basically as click house
doesn't have any primary key or indexes
but it has order by indexes
it has
such
such word as marks so it marks your data
certain sorted data and
somehow cluster it in
groups and then
click house will search only in a group
that is suitable for your filter that's
how quick house
helps you to make your queries even more
efficient
so next one is sample buy and basically
sample buy is something that is more
optional i would say but
your analysts will be very grateful if
you will set up a sample by index so
what does sample by
do does and
sample by index is index that help you
to helps you to
get your samples by a particular column
for example in statistics you would like
to
get
50 of all
advertisement banners that you had in
your advertising platform
and if you do not have any uh sample by
uh index it will get you
random rows but random roles it's not
the same as
random unique ids and we will cover that
in the next slide as well
so
you see when you have a raw data
with ad id event like click of view and
time
you can have
in this data
more than one ad id showing up and
for example your ad id can have two
clicks in different time and when you
would like to sample only at ids
you need to sample these them in this
way
but not in this way
as in the middle so
when
you do not have sampling index it will
just
take some random rows but you will
miss this row here
and it can be a problem if you do some
statistical manipulations with datum
but
if you would like to
have another column for sampling for
example you have also user id in your
data set but your sampling is ad id you
can apply city hash function
that already presented in
click house and these two queries uh
will
show you
same results
so you will have each second
at id in your database
yeah now we are moving to dictionary
engine
and
dictionaries is um something really
similar uh as you can imagine it can
have more than two
key values um
layers and
your dictionary can be applied to your
select queries
with a function dict cat so for example
you have a table
a white table with a lot of
events
and you write for each event
a city where this event
was held
and
it can be a problem if you store a lot
of strings
and like with the city names so
to avoid that you can write ids for
your
cities like one for moscow
two for saint petersburg if you live
here and
also you can
take dig get functions to apply
your
strings with names of the cities to it
then we will
move to materialized view and it's
something that really
does magic in click house
because for example probably you already
know about
views which are mostly
presented in all databases
and what view is uh when you write a
select query and then every time you
try to use this select query results it
will
just do this select query every time you
press the button run
but materialized you also have cache and
it stores
in some
cached form your data and helps you
to get this data more efficiently so
materialized view helps you to create a
real-time aggregate basically based on
your select queries and it is more
faster than a basic view
engine and here i would like to present
you
an example
just for understanding for example we
have in samsub
we can have such
documents with a lot of data on them and
we have ocr model that tries to find
some
text in this document and most
of our data
is stored in large quick house table
it is really similar to data lake and it
is stored in column called metadata
in json format
so for analytics it is not really proper
and we every time we write a select we
need to write json extract functions in
click house and your queries start to
look really huge so to avoid that we can
create a materialized view that will
transform this json data in metadata
column
to three columns and make you a standard
quick house wide table for product
analytics use
so how we do that
we just write another create table
query where you
show how you
how you knew table with materialized
view engine will
be named also you write here your query
and this is also native click house
functions
with json
extract you can extract rows strings ins
and a lot more
so we just extract all the needed data
from metadata that we have and after
that we will get our beautiful table
that is easy to use in project analytics
on a day-to-day basis
yeah so now we will move to uh variable
types uh we talked about this part of
the create table query and now we will
talk more about
this part
so basically click house isn't really
good working with
such types as string floats and nullable
notable
variable types
and when you have a lot of data huge
amounts of events in your click house
database
it is not really
efficient to store all this
data every time you write an event
basically you will
duplicate all them with a string and
it's really heavy for your memory so for
alternatives uh you have low cardinality
string it's
one more magic feature from click house
so what does lock ordinarity function
makes so it's just compressed
all your strings that you have
and create them in a more
efficient format for click house but for
you it's just a string so you will see
it as a basic string as
always
but
here is a important tip also
you need to
use only uh those list of strings that
are um
that have like um
not more than i would say 20 uh or 30 um
unique
values so if you have more values for
example you write down strings with
text from i don't know
from your
comments section and every other string
is different from
previous so here low cardinality
probably will not help you a lot
also
if you would like to write some floats
probably you need to
make a decision uh into other relational
databases or databases that are more
suitable for otp
if you have a lot of
columns with float
variables but if you can round them and
write ins do that and you will save a
lot of memory for your company
also
nullable is a special function in click
house that
writes a null variable
in a row
if
data is absent so
if you don't really
need to know that this data was missed
and you can write down zero instead of
that you can do 0 it it also will be
more lightweight
so now we are moving to syntax of click
house and i would like to show you how
basically all the functions in click
house are
made of in terms of syntax and words so
so for example we have a function array
we just can add to that
function uh another word and enumerate
and another function unique and now you
have
one new
function that calls
array enumerate unique and
basically a lot of functions in click
house
setting up by
this
set of words a set of even different
functions
so as with
conditional functions we have a basic
functions called if in click house where
you can just write condition
and
what you expect to be in your column
after that condition
but also you can use this if function
with the sum function count argument
function and a lot of more aggregating
functions so you're making from
conditional function and negative
function conditional aggregating
functions so you will have some if here
you can write a column for example money
and then after a comma you will just
write condition and calculate the money
only for for example
iphone platforms
and also click house
has mult multi-function
probably you heard of similar function
in sql
and structure of case
when
in click house
we have a multi-function for
that and it is more compact and probably
easy easier to read
also as i said
at the
start of the presentation
we have approximate calculation inside
the click house and also
with the functions that can be applied
in your queries
so like that
you can have a unique exact function and
unique function what does unique exact
is
calculating the unique amount of your ad
ids in your table and it will be really
precise and it is similar as count
distinct
and
it will have the same answers
but if you really do not need to know
how many
advertisements you have like
particularly for every advertisement and
you can
make it more approximate you can use
unique function it will work a lot more
faster and will provide you results with
some percentage
of difference
also we have a lot of array functions
and clear house we
can for example
when you do ranking in mysql you will
apply a window function but for click
house you will use group arrays and
array enumerate to
provide ranking for your ids
also click house has array map and it is
similar like for each loop in python
probably
so you can
set up a variable and
for each variable in an array you will
add
two and in the result you will have each
number in this array
with the plus two
also click house has a lot of analytical
functions uh that already
do a lot of work for you for example you
can have retention function that already
calculates all the retention
for example before i knew about this
function i did retention with joins but
you can avoid that and use this function
and
also they have window funnel and you can
calculate
how your events goes from
first event to the
goal event
also greek house
has a lot of ml functions and you can
use
machine learning inside your queries
inside your database
and
it's also very interesting and i think
that we need another
another presentation about ml
applications in click house
and also about some special syntaxes uh
in quick house we can use prewear it's
like where but it
uses
this filter to execute
your filters on the first place so
it will also save your time if you will
filter in this pre-wear query uh for
example for partitions or
some order by keys also in quick house
we have limit buy
and it helps you to
have a top for example of
some categories in a particular group
and also we have a sample and sample
we already mentioned earlier
and a little bit about
data stack that you can use with quick
house basically uh if s quick house now
used at uber at ebay and all that giants
it has already has a lot of
connections with different open source
and not open source tools
but
here i present like the simplest model
all your data that you would like to put
into click house is better to store
firstly in kafka because when you
store it here
you will not miss any data
if you would store if you would insert
it to click house directly
then from click house you can make some
aggregates from raw function raw data in
air flow and then you can visualize all
your data via for example superset it's
also apache
apache
open source tool
and yeah like that it worked at vk.com
it works it sums up and i also read a
lot of articles about such data stack
and you can also try to apply that
and yeah i hope that
it will inspire you to use quick house
somehow and you already like this guy
here waiting for click house
[Applause]
so questions
could you please um
give examples of
practical applications of click house
like right now in businesses uh in what
sectors did he supply
so sectors human like finance or
something like that
basically in all the spheres
as i worked in social network click
house was used there and now i work in
kyc company it is also used here
at e-commerce
basically they started as a company that
helped to save click stream data and it
was very applicable for attack for
advertisement data for all clicks and
views you have with your banners but now
it can be used in really many different
spheres
yeah as you already told you
have used materialized views to store
some
data from id cards right
the question is more about the solution
is that just experimental solution
because personally i would prefer to say
that kind of that in a traditional way
like using
any relational database or noisical
database
is that is that a solution with a
benefit or just experimentation
you know
honest answer is experimentation
but now i understand why it starts like
that because we have
a lot of different answers from ml
models and then not
every time like
particularly
really
[Music]
need to be stored in a relation database
and there are so many events and so many
answers from ml models
so that we just can't use them
you know in
relational basic databases and we need
more
more large data storage for
saving all this data
thankful for presentation i was
wondering whether
the click house can be like used with
multiple devices to make it very risky
because
currently i'm working with a huge data
set in lesbos and as i am a new industry
of data science i was like trying to
find a solution to make a
quick analysis
uh i was working with panda pandas
the
thing is that i switched to high spark
it's faster but it's not fast enough for
me and i was wondering whether i can
like apply a click house with multiple
devices yeah basically you can
by devices you mean like um
what do you mean by like different
devices it's like computers or machines
where you store the data
like cpu
okay yeah yeah it's uh
it can be even replicated by those cpus
and sharding between them and it will
also make this more efficient so you can
store your data at all your cpus you
have
and it will be very fast and probably
you will even
just
be satisfied with what you will have
with one machine already because uh
click house in my experience is
way more faster than hadoop and uh by
spark connection
so yeah try it out
thank you for the attention
you